foreign
just rushing forward headlessly where
are the ncos where are the officers
guiding them controlling the units doing
their best to keep people together I'm
Alexander Watson I'm professor of
history at Goldsmith's University of
London I'm an expert on the first world
war I've written three books and today
we're going to be looking at battle
scenes in first world war movies to
judge how real they are
thank you
in August 1914 Chicago plays quite an
important role we tend to think of the
first world war as being entirely static
but it did start off very mobile the
Germans stormed through Belgium and they
occupy a large chunk of Northeastern
France
some of the Cavalry was was equipped
with swords this was one of the things
that they were trained to do key
admission from how these British
cavalrymen are presented is that none of
them have rifles and that's a big
mistake because while British Cavalry
were trained to charge like they're
portrayed doing here they're also
trained to Scout and they were also
trained to act as mounted infantry so
they would Dismount and they would be
able to defend a position or work around
the flank of a position so they've got
multiple roles and that was actually
what made them so useful so this idea
that the film is going to hammer into
our heads that that
Cavalry are obsolete at this point it's
actually it's actually not true
[Applause]
all right so this is the point that
everything gets ridiculous but what they
have done is they've taken their machine
guns and they put them in a forest all
aimed at their camp and there are six
machine guns here six machine guns was
the allowance for an entire German
regiment in 1914. German regiment was
around 3 000 men so this number of
machine guns that would be expected to
support three thousand men in reality in
1914 you had about seven machine guns
for every two kilometers of ground you
wouldn't have arranged six machine guns
behind Three Trees this is the literal
definition of Overkill
thank you
as a cavalryman if you're confronted by
an entire regiment's worth of machine
guns or even just one which would be
sufficient why would you keep on
charging towards it that makes that
makes no sense what you would do is you
would Veer off to the left or to the
right you would get into cover there's
plenty of forest here and then you would
use your training as mounted infantry to
Dismount and try and take these machine
guns from the flank also as well Cavalry
in a forest if you charge into a forest
on a horse you're gonna break the
horse's legs this is a really really bad
idea
3 out of ten
[Music]
this is a great opening it's really good
to see the smoke that they've got in no
man's land this is 1916 the French
infantry are going into attack in order
to screen their infantry from uh machine
gun fire rifle fire the French would lay
smoke so that their troops could come
forward without easily being seen and
without easily being aimed at
and we've got an officer who is actually
leading the men this guy is desperately
trying to maintain control of his troops
to guide them to show which direction
they need to go it's great to see it so
often missed from first world war films
[Music]
foreign
are very authentic and what he's wearing
on his head is an Adrian helmet the
French army was the first of the armies
to introduce proper head protection for
its troops and that was because head
injuries in the first year of the war
were really really serious drain on
Manpower and so having his head
protection lowered injuries load
fatalities it's pretty light helmet a
bullet would penetrate it but it would
protect soldiers it would protect
soldiers from shrapnel this is an Adrian
helmet from the first world war this is
a medical core helmet the badges on the
front were different depending on what
arm the soldier belonged to see this is
a medical core one because it's got a
snake and a staff on it key thing is the
ridge the ridge it turns out was really
useful for protecting against the air
burst from shells like concussion I
think it was deliberate I think they
were basing it on a fire brigade helmet
but it turned out really really well
so this attack is is realistically
portrayed too the men are trying to keep
spaced out and that was really really
important all armies told men when you
go forward you need to keep space
between you because if you clumped
together then you presented a perfect
Target for a machine gun so keeping
spaced out was a really key aspect of
survival the other thing that you see
these French soldiers doing is using the
terrain for cover they're going in and
out of the dips in order to move forward
and protect themselves from machine gun
fire under really violent looking
artillery fire that's coming down on
them the one thing that it misses it's
got the French infantry all armed with
rifles and by this point in the war by
mid 1916 the French had already
developed a light machine gun I'd give
this an 8 out of ten
[Music]
we don't think of watches as weapons of
war but they really really were in the
first world war if you're going to have
a successful attack by 1917 everything
had to be synchronized the first wave
needed to go over together followed then
afterwards by the second wave but above
all you needed to synchronize with the
artillery behind you that's saying that
a lot of filmmakers forget that infantry
didn't simply act on their own they
acted in Combined arms with an artillery
bombardment so getting that timing right
was really really crucial and we see
that with the officer looking at his
watch that's that's that's a great start
with the scene
there is some historical context to this
say the battle of the Somme huge battle
half a million casualties on on both
sides
took place in the second half of 1916
and the Germans really suffered badly
and they decided to withdraw their lines
back to Stronger positions in early 1917
and the the back story here is is that
the the British army is pursuing them
this is a temporary trench so that's why
there aren't any sandbags it's simply
been dug to protect the assaulting
troops this meant to take place on the
song or just beyond the some Battlefield
and the the ground there was really
chalky it was known to be white and
chalky and they've really represented
that well in the film
[Music]
I never understand why he goes over the
parapet in a first world trench you've
got kind of two mounds of Earth one
behind it one in front of it the one in
front of it's called the parapet that's
the one that soldiers will shoot over
the other one is called the parados and
that was actually built slightly higher
than the parapet and the reason for that
was that if the soldier put his head up
over the parapit and if there wasn't any
Earth behind him then he would be you'd
have the Horizon he'd be either silly
seen now there's going to be an attack
and all of these troops are going to go
over the parapare why doesn't he just
climb over the Paradox there's nobody
there he could simply run unimpeded
without any problems he'd even get some
cover from the from the guys going over
the parapet
[Music]
send your men forward without any
artillery support
everybody is going to die they didn't
send men over like this the the
guidelines that the Army releases in
early 1917 is that when you advance you
need to advance with the artillery and
you have what's called a creeping
barrage
and what a creeping barrage was was a
line of shells which would Pummel the
ground in front of the Infantry and move
forward at set times and they did that
in order to clear no man's land of any
Defenders so you need to be rid of them
and then moving into the trenches to
keep the defender's heads down which you
desperately needed to do if everyone
wasn't going to be machine gun to death
so
by this point April 1917 you're gonna
only go forward with a creeping barrage
generally you're not going to do it any
other way and that's just absent from
here everybody is just rushing forward
headlessly if they actually get to the
generalizer which they're clearly not
going to do because they've got any
artillery support but what are they
going to do once they're there where are
the ncos where are the officers guiding
them controlling the units doing their
best to keep people together
[Music]
helmets that they use were called Brody
helmets and they were above all designed
to protect against shrapnel because if
you think about the position that these
soldiers are in they're actually
defended very well on either side by the
trench itself trenches really were very
effective at protecting soldiers it's
only when soldiers leave the trenches
that they become extremely vulnerable
where they are vulnerable though is on
the top of their heads and so that was
why you had this kind of battle bowler
type arrangement with uh hardened steel
and the rim around it to protect the
head above all that was why they were
designed like this I'd give it a four
[Music]
you hear them shouting in German to Arms
to arms and then this machine gun opens
up and that seems to be very very
plausible and then they switch on a
Searchlight which was pretty common on
the Eastern Front you'd have
searchlights you could switch on to
illuminate the front of your defenses
this is representing the so-called
Christmas battles of early 1917 and this
is a unit called the Latvian Rifleman
they were a nationalist Latvian units
that were raised and that served in the
Imperial Russian army operating up on
the North of the Eastern front in what
today is Latvia and this was a really
marshy area
so it wasn't possible to dig trenches in
this area this is the Eastern Front this
is different from the West when the
germs took it in 1915 what they did was
they built a long wall made of sand and
wood
which they fortified and you can see
that really well
[Applause]
the other aspect of this scene that's
authentic is that when the Latvian
rifles attacked this part of the German
line they had to get through the barbed
wire you had to find a way without
blowing the barbed wire up using
artillery they relied on surprise alone
they didn't have any artillery
bombardment and what we're seeing here
is what the British army would have
called a Bangalore torpedo which was
like a point bomb it was pushed
underneath the wire and then it had a
fuse going back and then you'd light it
and that's what these two guys are doing
here they've got these uh hardened metal
plates in front of them to try and
protect them from bullets and it's their
job to light the fuse which will then
send off the wire
[Music]
foreign
you see this wave of Riflemen coming out
disguised in in snow camouflage they
would have been bed sheets or any white
material that they could have got hold
of the other thing that's great about
this clip is that it reminds us that the
winter could actually be a point of
really huge activity if you want to take
an area that's a marsh though actually
you can't do that for most of the year
the only point in which you can do it is
when the marsh freezes over and that's
what happened in January 1917 and that
was when these Latvian troops went
forward and attacked this German line
they could suddenly get over the marsh
what you see is the main character he's
dropping to the ground he's taking cover
behind a corpse as the machine gun moves
towards him and then you see
a line of soldiers falling one after the
other from right to left and it's clear
that the machine gun is traversing back
away from him and he leaps up and he
moves to the left away from the machine
guns fire and this is what gives him the
opportunity to uh to throw a hand grade
and destroy the gun and it's a really
neat way of uh of showing how an
experienced combat troop would be very
alert to uh to what was going on to
where the machine gun was fine and
Veteran troops did learn ways how to
deal with it's part of the learning
process that goes on in the first World
War
it's just such a nice human detail that
they managed to get this far right to
the wall in part thanks to the snow
because the marsh is frozen but then
they can't easily get up this slope
because it's icy and so they're using
their bare Nets as ice axes in order to
in order to carve some sort of foothold
in it you can see the desperation there
and it's just this tiny little detail
that just makes this scene so totally
plausible I think this is fantastic I
give this a 10.
foreign
fictional naval battle between a Russian
destroyer and a German armored Cruiser
in the Baltic Sea what's hinted at in
the clip but what maybe doesn't come
through as well as it could is that
these two ships are of a massively
different size there's literally nothing
this Russian Destroyer could have done
to to hurt this this Cruiser if some of
them were equipped with Torpedoes and
that potentially could have done but as
becomes clear in this film this
particular ship is equipped with mines
so there really isn't any defense that
this ship has has got against the
Friedrich Karl
the Cruiser has multiple guns but the
biggest on it 21 centimeters if those 21
centimeters hit the Russian Destroyer
it's gonna sink or at the very least
it's gonna have its infrastructure wiped
off it it's gonna be a huge amount of
damage
huge German shell hits this gun tear and
it's not even the gun tag goes down the
the gun is still in working order
there's nothing realistic about this at
all
you'd be very unlikely to have combat
this close either the German armored
Cruiser would have destroyed the Russian
ship before it got anywhere near it
it's true that the Friedrich Karl was
sunk by mine if a German ship hit a mine
you would get an explosion but down near
the water line there would be no reason
to have this huge explosion that they've
produced on the bridge or on the deck
that's that's doesn't make any sense
there was an explosion but it sank
really really slowly it didn't explode
in flames and in the end
the Germans managed to rescue all the
eight people this idea that there was a
fight between a destroyer and the armed
Cruiser that's not the case I'll give it
a two the battle itself is pure make
believe thanks so much for watching if
you want to see more videos in this
series click on the link above